la passion des animaux jusque pendant
les heures de pause au lycée agricole le
béa
les élèves du club nature créée il ya
deux ans prennent soin des tourterelles
rougequeue noir et pivert qui peuplent
le parc l'hiver ce lycée d'enseignement
privé est le seul possédant une filière
animalerie dans toute l'ile-de-france
sanctionnée par un diplôme reconnu
alors cette filière on apprend les bases
des animaux de compagnie c'est à dire on
apprend à peu près l'équivalent de 300
espèces animales rongeurs aquariophilie
oiseaux mais aussi reptiles sont au
programme
car les nac nouveaux animaux de
compagnie sont de plus en plus prisés on
appellera python bull
le python bull un serpent qui peut
atteindre un mètre cinquante et tue ses
proies par constriction le spécimen
n'effraie pas les élèves
les boues pour les animaux ont largement
évolué dérangeant pour simhat ans et
plus les régimes ce que je suis passé le
toucher et roux c'est une nouveauté
quand les élèves qui viennent de partout
en france n'ont qu'une seule motivation
je cite et verdière tout simplement par
passion
reptiles et poissons ici une centaine
d'élèves est réparti entre les classes
de seconde de première et de terminale
d'autres choisissent l'apprentissage ou
le bts technico-commercial 70 à 80 % des
élèves se dessine qu'à la vente en
animalerie
d'autres se dirigent vers les métiers de
l'assistanat au vétérinaire ou encore
vers l'élevage l'animalerie reste l'un
des secteurs qui recrutent encore
aujourd'hui et si le respect des animaux
fait partie intégrante de l'enseignement
du lycée le respect de l'environnement
aussi le lycée agricole qui s'agrandit
actuellement a été distingué par un
écolabel